hey everyone and welcome back sorry for
the nasally voice on my end kissing lots
of dudes over the weekend and it looks
like it finally caught up to me uh just
a quick announcement before we actually
get into the content of today is that I
just want to shout out one of my viewers
Ty who reached out to me over LinkedIn
to tell me that he got four senior
offers recently primarily studying the
content from this very channel so to
those of you who are haters believe in
this channel take your own notes be like
Ty and go get to the bag anyways let's
get into the content of today's video
sorry again about my voice but we'll get
through it we're going to be talking
about bee trees how they work and what
they're good for
all right so I decided to do a bunch of
pre-drawing so that we wouldn't have to
wait for me to draw everything and my
handwriting would be worse but let's go
ahead and actually start talking about
what a b tree is so a b tree is another
type of database index so I started last
episode by talking about hash indexes
and how that's basically just a hash map
kept in memory on the other hand the
cool thing about a b tree is that it's
kept entirely on disk so it doesn't have
some of the downsides that hash maps
have right we don't have to keep all of
our keys in memory and you know we don't
have to worry about the durability of
our index well for the most part we'll
talk about the cases where we might so
basically the B tree as we can see from
the iPad is this tree-like structure
where it basically gives the ranges of
all the keys and gives references to
other locations on disk that we have to
Traverse to in order to go ahead and
find the row that we want so you can see
written out here let's imagine we have a
bunch of names and the scores that they
got on a math test so basically all the
rows from a to L we can see there's a
reference pointer that leads us and
basically says okay now follow and
Traverse the reference from a to e if
you want those names or if you care
about the names between E and O we can
go and Traverse to this Leaf node which
is basically going to have something
like Edward with a score of 80 and
Gordon with a score of 95. so the point
is we can Traverse through this tree
basically going to the reference that
matches up with the range of key that we
want and this is really really great for
a couple of reasons so one is that this
is relatively Speedy for reads why
because to actually go and find the key
that we want all we have to actually do
is follow these references right or in
this case it's not this reference that
we want but it's this one here typically
I didn't draw it out completely but the
speed tree is going to stay balanced
we'll talk about how that works in a
little bit and so that's really really
useful for making sure that the height
of the tree is relatively constant and
additionally these page sizes right here
are typically pretty big I can't
remember the exact amount but I think
it's typically something like 250
megabytes and if it's 256 megabytes or
250 or whatever it means that we can
have a tree that encompasses a ton uh we
can have a tree that encompasses tons of
keys and values uh while also staying
relatively short and that means we're
jumping around on fewer places on disk
because keep in mind on the actual ring
that is the disc all of these references
are in different locations so jumping
around is actually pretty tough but if
we only have to do it a couple of times
that's relatively fast so for both
reading and updating the general process
is actually just traversing through the
tree finding where it is that the key
that we want to look at already exists
if it's an update then we just go ahead
and update it in place and if it's a
read we can go ahead and read it well
what about her rights this is where
things get a little bit more complicated
so I'm going to draw out another diagram
all right so let's talk about actually
writing so let's imagine that I wanted
to basically this is like a you know one
root two Leaf path in our B tree and
let's imagine that I wanted to add the
key Betty with a score of let's say 90.
right so basically the fundamental thing
here to remember is that every single
kind of node of the B tree has a set
size let's imagine it's 256 Megs
and so let's imagine now that we have
this kind of bottom node right here
if it has extra space we're in pretty
good shape right it means we can
actually just add Betty right over here
and we'll be fine because we don't
actually have to change the structure of
the B tree at all the one thing to note
is that Adam Bob and Betty still needs
to remain in alphabetical sorted order
so we do actually have to kind of write
this one particular node right we would
go and make one over here with Adam
Betty you know or rather Adam Betty and
Bob
and then we would change the reference
to this page so that's how you would
write if there is actually space in this
child node however what if there isn't
space in the leaf node then things
actually become complicated so now what
actually has to happen is I would have
to split the child node into two so I
might have one node with Adam and Betty
sorry I'm trying to write here and then
the other with just Bob and then how can
I actually go ahead and rectify this
well now I have to go ahead and split
the parent node right but you might
actually see here that this parent node
doesn't have enough space in it right so
ideally what we would want to do is
basically delineate the parent node to
have some boundary
where what we're effectively doing is
saying here's everything from A to B E
and then here's everything from
Bo to C right because Bob De C is over
in this other page and that would refer
to here and then this one would be
referred to by this reference sorry it's
getting a little bit messy however if
there's no space in this node we
basically have to keep traversing up
through the B tree splitting every
single node into two pieces until we
actually find free space in one of the
notes as you can see there is some free
space in this route So eventually we'll
be in good shape if the root itself
doesn't have free space we actually have
to split the root itself into two
different pieces and then create a new
root node all the way on top of it which
points down to the old root node so I
know that's a little bit of a convoluted
explanation but you can think it out the
point is by making sure to split these
pages when they get too big we can
guarantee that our B tree is going to
remain balanced so there's actually an
issue here and one of those things is
what if for example you know we're
updating a node and then basically B
tree dies and what I mean by that is
computer turns off you know mid B tree
update
and for example now the references are
all out of whack we've created these two
pages right here
but we haven't actually updated the
reference in time so now our B tree is
in a consistent in inconsistent State
computer dies
well if you recall from last episode the
best thing to do to ensure that you can
always get your state back is to have
something like a write ahead log right
our sequential only right log that tells
us everything that we're about to do in
our database before we actually do it so
every single time before we actually
write to the B tree or update the B tree
that's first going in the right ahead
log then if the computer were to die we
can actually go and replay all of these
messages to recover the state of our B
tree
okay so let's summarize our B tree again
in terms of how it compares to the
actual hash index itself obviously it is
going to be slower right that's because
the primary amount of data in the index
is kept on disk which is always going to
be slower than memory that being said
the B tree relatively speaking is still
not bad it's relatively good in terms of
reads because you only have to do a
couple of traversals on disk in addition
the main advantage to the B tree over
something like the hash index is twofold
first of all not all of the keys have to
fit in memory we can now have a much
bigger size in our data set and even
more importantly we can do range queries
so if you recall range queries are when
we want keys that are similar to one
another adjacent to one another in
memory or on disk so that we can find
them if you look at the actual child
structure of a b tree we can see that
the keys that are similar to one another
are actually going to be next to each
other in these child pages so this way
if I want say all the keys between e and
l i can just go down the tree reference
back to this child mode fetch all of
them at once I don't have to do a bunch
of different reads the data is
conveniently effectively sorted through
this B tree so just to summarize it and
write this out
a b tree is the following it is a
self-balancing tree on disk
and that means one
no limits
to data set size within reason of course
obviously hard drives do have bigger
capacities but they're not infinite
and then the second and more important
point is that now we actually have
support for range queries
the one thing to note is that even
though B trees are relatively quick with
reading the rights themselves are not
super fast for the reasons we discussed
you may actually have to do a bunch of
Rights not only to the right ahead log
but to the bottom of the tree and then
you may have to Traverse all the way
back up the tree basically switching all
of these references on disks so that can
take a while we'll talk about in the
next video a different type of index
that tries to optimize on this and kind
of improve the write speed while at
least maintaining similar read speeds to
the B tree and a similar ability to
perform range queries alright guys have
a good one and I will see you in the
next video